let's talk about uh deceptive headlines
that can be written to achieve political
goals i hope that this segment is a good
snapshot of how headlines can be used to
distort and to influence and to
um push a particular narrative that may
be interesting to one media outlet
versus another so what happened well joe
biden was recently asked during his
current trip to asia
about chinese aggression towards taiwan
now that's a legitimate issue we've
talked about it on this program will
china see the chaos of what's happening
in ukraine thanks to the russian
invasion as maybe an opening in which
they could make a military move against
taiwan so china taiwan that's the issue
it's a real issue it's a legitimate
issue president joe biden was asked
about it and joe biden confirmed
if china invaded taiwan
um the u.s would intervene and that's
been american policy for a long time so
let's look at the actual question and
answer this is the source material
for the topic and the subsequent
headlines we're going to look at you
didn't want to get involved in the
ukraine conflict militarily for obvious
reasons are you willing to get involved
militarily to defend taiwan if it comes
to that yes
you are
that's the commitment we made okay so
that's not news it's there's nothing
there that's actually newsworthy
there's something called the one china
policy
you can agree with the one china policy
or you can disagree with it but the
policy has been dating all the way back
to 1979 it was first started uh stated
in 1972 the u.s acknowledges that china
on either side of the taiwan strait
maintain there is
but one china and that taiwan is a part
of china that's the united states
position
now in 2016 donald trump said the u.s
isn't necessarily bound by the one china
policy and lots of people said oh my
goodness trump is trying to change the
one china policy but then in a phone
call in 2017 that trump had with
xi jinping they talked about a number of
different things and trump agreed at the
request of president xi to honor the one
china policy okay so we have that
we also have the taiwan relations act
from 1979 and we have the six assurances
as they're called that reagan gave to
taiwan in 1982
which say that if taiwan violates the
principles the u.s
uh uh believes in
um
or if a rather if china violates the
principles that the u.s believes in the
u.s would help taiwan to defend itself
um if china were to invade the united
states would help taiwan in that
situation so this has been policy for a
really long time so biden is asked
during the press conference well if uh
china attacks would the u.s help defend
taiwan and the united states president
says yes that's the commitment we made
it's not news biden is essentially
saying
the stuff we've agreed to
for the last 40 years
we're going to abide by it that's it
that's the story
check out how every news corporation
media outlet covered it and by me by
news corp we mean fox fox business wall
street journal the wall street journal
titled their article
biden says u.s would intervene
militarily if china invaded taiwan fox
news says u.s military will defend
taiwan if it comes to that biden says
fox business segment
says biden says u.s will intervene if
china invades taiwan now again
it's not about these headlines being
literally false it's the fact that
they're being written specifically to
further the idea of biden's out there
looking for wars biden's out there
looking for military conflict and it was
trump who was keeping us out of wars
this has been the narrative in the
george w bush era the right loved war
they loved spreading democracy and all
of this different stuff and then trump
came in and trump said the iraq war was
a bad idea even though previously trump
had said i would have gone into iraq
doesn't matter trump came in and said
iraq was bad which is true uh just he's
a hypocrite on it and he said hillary
will get us into wars but i won't i'm
going to keep us out of wars and get us
out of more places
and then the claim made about joe biden
was biden's going to get us into wars
biden's bloodthirsty biden's war hungry
even though there was no such evidence
of that
and so
they want to write headlines that will
further that and most of the fox
audience probably doesn't realize most
of the wall street journal audience
doesn't realize the u.s has previously
said
we would help to defend taiwan in such a
case biden's not
treading new ground here biden's not
changing policy he's not announcing new
policy but the story that fox wants to
tell is here's biden once again looking
for military problems so they'll say
look at biden wanting to intervene
look at biden wanting to interject and
inject the military the truth is biden's
saying i'm not changing the 40-year
policy that we've had now comparatively
reuters had a more straightforward
headline for the story reuters called it
no change in u.s policy towards taiwan
says white house official now it's not
only fox opting for the more salacious
headlines most of them do it cnn had a
similar one but it's at least more fair
cnn's headline was biden says u.s would
respond militarily if china attacked
taiwan
but white house insists there's no
policy change and indeed there isn't so
it's really important to understand
how to research these things directly if
you were uh to google
one china policy
six assurances to taiwan u.s
relationship to china and taiwan you
would realize there's not a newsworthy
element here joe biden is just saying
like yeah this is the policy and we're
going to stick to the policy the story
is biden doesn't unilaterally change
anything when it comes to china and
taiwan that doesn't really make
for a very exciting headline so that's
the
genesis the oranges for lack of a better
term
of a bunch of these headlines and
hopefully instructive in understanding
how these narratives can be woven